this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base
a subscription website where you can
download thousands of medical images
and videos to use in lectures courses
presentations professional training
and more for more information click on
the link in the description
if you have a condition in your neck
that puts pressure on your spinal cord
or spinal nerves
your doctor may recommend a cervical
laminoplasty
the spine in your neck also called the
cervical spine
has seven bones called vertebrae
the front part of each vertebra is
called the vertebral body
except for the first vertebra
between most vertebrae is a soft cushion
of cartilage
called an intervertebral disc
the back part of each vertebra has a
curved section
called the vertebral arch
except for the first vertebra each
vertebral arch has a bony projection
called the spinous process
on each side of the spinous process is a
flat piece of
bone called a lamina
the vertebral arch of the vertebra
surrounds and protects your spinal cord
a column of nervous tissue connecting
your brain to other nerves in your body
your spinal cord passes through an
enclosed space
called the vertebral canal which is
formed by the vertebral arches of your
vertebrae
over time your cervical spine may
develop problems
such as a bulging disc
or bony growths on your vertebrae called
bone spurs
these changes can narrow your vertebral
canal
and put pressure on your spinal cord or
the nerves that branch off of it
the pressure can cause neck pain and
stiffness
or pain numbness and weakness in your
arms or hands
before your procedure an intravenous
line or
iv will be started
you may be given antibiotics through the
iv to decrease your chance of infection
you will be given general anesthesia to
make you unconscious
and pain-free during the procedure
a breathing tube will be inserted
through your mouth and down your throat
to help you breathe during the operation
your surgeon will make an incision on
the back of your neck
the laminae of the affected vertebrae
will be exposed
your surgeon will remove the outer layer
of bone from each lamina
forming two troughs if your surgeon uses
the
open door technique he or she will cut
the rest of the way through one of the
troughs
and pull open the vertebral arch using
the other trough as a hinge
this relieves the pressure on your
spinal cord
if your surgeon uses the french door or
double door variation on this technique
both troughs will be used as hinges
this will allow your surgeon to split
the spinous process
and open your vertebral arch in the
middle
usually the vertebral arch will be
opened on more than one of your cervical
vertebrae
bone graft material along with metal
plates attached to it
may be inserted into each vertebral arch
to hold it open
your surgeon will close your incision
with sutures
surgical skin glue or staples
your neck will be placed in a collar to
keep it still
while your bones heal
after your procedure your breathing tube
will be removed
and you will be taken to the recovery
area for monitoring
you'll be given pain medication as
needed
you will wear your neck collar for
several weeks
you may be released from the hospital
within two to three days
after your procedure